more phone calls coming up best and
worst of the weekend what you saw that
you liked
you didn't like you know let me start
there with reggie miller the hall of
famer
best and worst of the weekend reg what
was the best thing you saw what was the
worst thing you saw
it's been interesting because i wanted
to see
how the celebrations would be in the
conference finals
being in an environment like that
usually we're used to
when a team clinches usually it's on
their home
floor in front of their home fans fans
going crazy
you know players crying you know all
that stuff
but i got to give credit to the nba they
had the
confetti shooters out they tried to make
it as real as possible
um little thing i was surprised about
they didn't
allow the family members on the court
with the players
they're still being pretty stickler even
though they're in the bubble with them
um they're still keeping them somewhat
separated so for what they had to work
with
that was probably the best thing i saw
is because i wanted to see how those
celebrations
would be the worst thing for me my
angels are not going to be part of
the baseball playoffs that's the worst
thing for me
theodore uh mike trout for the sixth
straight year
the best player in bat and baseball
will not be a part of the postseason
that's the worst thing for me
he's been in the league ten years and
he's only played in three playoff games
amazing amazing that the best player how
many mvps does he have now three four
something like that
i think three and he's finished
runner-up or in the top three a couple
of times
as well it's it's mind-boggling that
we have not witnessed him on the biggest
stage
against the best pitching and the best
teams
a chance to perform so i keep my fingers
crossed
every year next year will be our mike
trout you're winning it all next year
my angels go angel all right if lebron
wins does that change anything in the
big picture of how he's viewed
in history no i think his legacy
has been set for a while um
one thing i am hoping if the lakers
were to win and lebron is finals
mvp that's something no one in the
history
of the game has don has done be able to
win
three championships with three different
organizations
and be finals mvp on those teams
so not larry bird not kareem obviously
not michael
no not magic none of the other greats
have been able to achieve that to lead
three different teams to three different
championships
and win the finals mvp that would be
kind of cool to see which would kind of
separate him from a little bit
but i think his legacy has already said
theodore he can't
get any higher than what he is in europe
is he the second greatest player of all
time
i would put i'm gonna go with mj1
and i'm going to go with kareem and
lebron
mixed in in that next level um
in terms of everything that they've
contributed to the game
um i put kobe someone in there as well i
say i'm not always looking at
championships okay i'm looking at
impact okay impact on the game
so that's why i have mj number one and
again lebron too he's in the social
media age too something those other guys
didn't have to deal with that's why
lebron
numbers and and his stature is so much
bigger is because
he's in the dawn of uh facebook
instagram twitter and so forth how do
the lakers not win this
it's theirs to lose it really is uh they
will
always have the two best players on the
floor
in this series um they're well coached
uh they have championship experience
obviously lebron james this is his 10th
nba finals don't forget about danny
green and rajon rondo
both of those guys have won
championships so to me
it's theirs to lose having said all that
something is special is going on in
miami
and people ask who do i have if i have
to
make a pick and this is coming from the
heart
this is a lot like when the lakers
played the detroit pistons
i believe in early 2000 when no one
really gave
the detroit pistons any chance i knew
detroit was going to win that series
because
during that series with us in detroit i
was begging our guys
jermaine and ron and al harrington i was
like
do you guys understand whoever wins this
series between us and the pistons is
going to win the championship
i was like i wasn't even thinking about
kobe in the lakers because i knew at
that time defense won
championship detroit was such a together
team and i see a lot of that in the
miami heat
so i'm picking miami in seven
the lakers should win they're gonna be
very top heavy to win
odds on favorite to win but it's just
something special
all season long and especially since the
restart
that miami and that culture of pat riley
and eric spoelstra
i'm picking the heat in seven but
i expect the lakers to win is that fair
enough to say
yeah i i mean you you just pick both
teams but i
no no miami and seven but the lakers
should win
but miami and seven okay but
you know you said that this doesn't
change lebron's legacy if he wins
if he loses does it do anything
to that
no because i think people are expected
he's he's going to be a top five player
no matter what
he is numbers alone um
and we got to think about this he's been
in the nba
17 years 17 seasons and he's been to the
finals 10 times
that's amazing i mean that is amazing
in today's age with a lot more parody i
mean this is not the
60s celtics right where there was what
eight
12 teams back then there's 30 teams now
there's better parity it's an amazing
feat so
if he loses no it doesn't change
anything he still
is going to be in the top three in my
opinion the
third best player on the lakers is who
our third most important player who's
ever making shots at the current time
i think it in that last series versus
denver
it was probably rondo and his impact off
the bench along with kcp
i thought kcp was fantastic not only
guarding
murray which he did a great job but
he was making shots who should it be it
should be kuzma and he's kind of been
up and down um i thought caruso played
great
the role players are have started to
come around
and fill the roles a little bit but
they're facing a different team in miami
because if they allow did you see how
many wide open shots
that denver missed between jeremy grant
gary harris uh tori craig
you give those looks to tyler hero
duncan robinson jay crowder
it's a different story so their defense
has to be
much better versus miami than it was
versus denver
and i said this earlier and uh some
people push back on this but i i still
believe it i think miami is a better
all-around team i think they can go
maybe eight or nine deep and you can get
contributions you can sometimes get a
a career night out of somebody as we've
seen with them
um you know the lakers got the two great
players but
you know bam is a force to be reckoned
with jimmy butler is great
at the end of games hero duncan robinson
can shoot goran dragach can be
you know very difficult match up there
jay crowder is a tough guy to have
spolster's been there before it's a
really interesting roster that
pat riley has built here and here's the
thing too
jimmy butler has had success going
against lebron james
when he was in the eastern conference
whether he was with
chicago and understanding when he was
with miami
that dynamic they've locked horns a lot
of times so he's familiar
with playing against lebron and they do
have a number of people that they can
throw at lebron because that's what you
have to do
so you're going to put jay crowder on
him as well i think bam out of bio will
get
a lot of time guarding lebron james too
my only concern with the heat
will be their length and their depth
because you've got
javel mcgee who didn't play a lot last
series dwight howard and anthony davis
i mean that's you know almost 21 feet of
length right there there's not a lot of
bigs on miami
rebounding will be paramount but tyler
hero
rebounds great for his position so gang
rebounding will be
key um and second chance points but
miami plays fantastic nose to nose
defense i think this is going to be a
great series
these are the two best teams that have
played the best since the restart it's
no surprise
and people's like there's no milwaukee
there's no toronto the one two seeds
no the two best teams playing the best
basketball or in the nba finals and we
should appreciate that
turner sports analyst hall of famer
reggie miller joining us on the program
i was looking at i'm you know i'm
keeping an eye on mike d'antoni where
he's going to end up i i think new
orleans
would make more sense but now there's
talk that maybe
the 76ers and if he goes to philadelphia
would he trade joel embiid
and try to get james harden from the
rockets there
that's an interesting trade i i can see
that
but if you trade away
arguably the best center in the game and
he kind of fits into dan tony style
because he is a big that can shoot
threes
i know he's he's more effective with his
back to the basket
but he can face you up and knock down a
three
my question is why would you trade him
and maybe not ben simmons
who really wouldn't fit into a mike and
tony system because he's not a
three-point shooter
so i don't know how he would fit into
our dan tony system
more so than what joelle and b
i agree with you new orleans seems like
more like his style
they can get up and run and shoot a
bunch of threes
i don't know about philadelphia but what
you can get more for
embiid i'm guessing i think he didn't
get a lot for ben simmons too
yeah but how does he fit in today's game
i know that he's a
he's a good defender he's a a you know a
match-up nightmare
but it's i don't know like him and lonzo
ball like these guys who play point but
can't shoot
like what's the value there in today's
nba are you talking about ben simmons
and lonzo
well well no just you could put out ben
you know we know about lonzo and you
know his shot is his shot i don't know
if
ben's going to get better either but how
valuable is ben simmons in today's nba
well he's a guy that said 16 can push
the ball and puts a lot of pressure in
the open court the problem is
come playoff time and this is why
houston has always had so much
problem during the regular season it's a
track meet you don't prepare for them
the same way
you get into a series where you're
seeing a team
five six seven time times potentially
you take away most of their strengths
and most of those strengths for houston
was in the open court and it's very
difficult for them to play half court
basketball because you're taking away
those things
and that would be the problem wherever
d'antoni went if he's gonna
do the seven seconds or less and just
jack up a bunch of threes
what is your plan come play off
basketball that's what i would be asking
mike gentile
yeah and i don't know if he's gonna
change his coaching philosophy i mean
he's what
upper 60s he's almost 70 years i don't
think he's changing anything
and is he the right coach for zion
williamson
he could be look here's the thing with
mike d'antoni he's going to have options
and you can throw indiana in there as
well because they would love to have
mike antonia as well so he's going to
have his pick on where he wants to go
to me it's all about personnel i
personally think new orleans will
probably fit a little bit better because
they have more
weapons for him to work with offensively
yeah how about all the kentucky alum
in the finals and balling too right
jamal murray tyler hero bam adebayo
i mean well frank frank vogel went to
kentucky pat riley went to kentucky
yeah so it's uh it's alumni
night there did did kentucky recruit you
no
i wasn't on their radar no i was lucky
to get into ucla again
you and i we've had this conversation
before they wanted the other reggies
before this reggie they wanted reggie
williams and reggie lewis
and they opted to go somewhere else and
i was the last reggie on there
on their radar and i was lucky to get in
wait where else were you going if you
didn't go to ucla
i had it down to two i headed down to
cal state fullerton
if and i headed down to arizona state
those were my
my two teams i know right and then ucla
came in last minute and every kid
here from the south wind wants to play
for ucla and when they came in the last
minute i was like
fullerton arizona state who who are you
guys
what this is ucla recruiting me huh what
goodbye and they pay a whole lot better
hey damn gilbert was gone when i came in
he was gone what what did your sister
what kind of offers did cheryl get now
cheryl's the number one player in high
school
and probably could have played for some
men's teams as well she was that
talented in my opinion right
yes what were they were they paying or
offering under the table
for cheryl to go to a women's program
uh they were not paying but
let's just say she was going to be able
to drive around
campus in style wherever she
went not that usc that
other school did that
[Laughter]
what what what what what kind of car did
cheryl drive at usc
my mind is blocky i can't remember
your zoom connection yeah all i know is
she used to pick me up i was a freshman
and she was a sophomore and i rise back
to
riverside we were in style
[Laughter]
but when you went to her games in high
school
what was that like they were events
they were events they weren't games
because in riverside when cheryl played
in high school
people came from everywhere they like
they put the men's game our game like as
the jv games
that's how big they were they had to
move them to bigger arenas
because her team and cheryl they were
like phenomenal
they came from like riverside in the
palm springs area in the big berry area
people would just flood uh our
gymnasium just to watch her just to
watch her warm up
it was an event it wasn't a game it was
an event
i like how you guys were the you're the
varsity the men's varsity basketball
team
and we were good we were like ranked
number one or two and we were the jv
game like our game started at six and
her game started on eight
i still one of my favorite stories is
when reg had
an unbelievable game i don't know you
had like 38 in the game
i think or something 45 okay here i am
i'm gonna finally top my sister
i had 45 on the road you know coming
back
gloating yes sis yeah what did you do
oh nothing i just had a cool 105.
i'm like i look like dad
he's like just laughing shaking his head
i'm like i know y'all playing
right like you guys scored 105 as a team
no
son she had 105
they as a team had 179
100 first of all
how is that possible in a high school
game with eight minute quarters
and no shot clock no shot clock
and and we have the clip of when uh
cheryl interviewed kobe
about 10 years ago when she dropped a
passion bucket
uh it sounded like this most unusual
but superb game for kobe bryant 17
points
i'm gonna assist five rebounds and he is
with
[Music]
how much fun will the remainder of this
season be it'll be a lot of fun you know
we're playing with a full fashion bucket
tonight oh
kobe kobe had heard it on the show
passion bucket
and then all of a sudden he threw that
in there when he's interviewed by cheryl
let me just say this and this is why
cheryl was great for so many years on
television especially
at our network at turner because the
players
absolutely knew i mean this is the
greatest women's basketball player of
all time and they respected her so much
she was almost like one of the guys so
they could joke around
and she knew the vernacular because she
had she had been in those wars with them
really created those wars so they
respected cheryl so much
it was almost like they were talking to
one of their teammates and you kind of
got a sense of that from kobe bean right
there
uh great to talk to you again as always
we'll be checking in with you and uh
once again
reg with his heart is picking the miami
heat to win
in seven thank you rich all right buddy
appreciate theodore buddy that's reggie
aloysius miller junior iii